- Instagram Stories?
I'm playing with it.
I'm making my
first story right now.
It's a wait-and-see.
I think it's important.
Unexpected but exciting.
Instagram Stories suck.
Instagram Stories?
(light music)
What you think is the biggest
thing I can bring to them?
- [Man] I would
say personal, how--
- Thank you so much.
Thanks.
- [Man] you develop your
market, your personal brand.
I would say how you
communicate with your people.
Right?
- So even if I go at
least saw it in my paper.
I love when it's a smaller room
because I want to give them,
I can pontificate forever but
giving a direct answer is
always, you know, inevitably
in a size like this that guy's
question is what 80%
are thinking as well.
Questions.
- [Man 2] You
mentioned it earlier.
Briefly, when you hear
insurance, positive or negative?
Right, so exactly.
Can everything that
you're laying out for us--
- Work?
- [Man 2] change that
in the midst of a public
that's got a negative attitude?
- No, unless there's whatever
that is the biggest insurance
organization in America is,
the mothership, unless
they spend real money.
You need to spend 10, 20
you want to change America's
perception of you characters
you need to spend tens
of millions of dollars.
- [Man 2] Right.
- Awesome.
Thank you guys.
(applause)
Thanks having me.
Thank you.
Thank you, buddy.
Alright, take care, my man.
- You're leaving already?
- [Gary] Yeah, I gotta go.
See you later.
- See ya.
- Take care guys.
- [Man 3] See you guys.
Safe travels.
- See you.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- [Gary] I think we got
real practical with them.
- [Woman] I love how you just
did the half hour and
turned it to Q&amp;A and--
[Gary] That's
where it got better.
- [Woman] It made about them.
- [Gary] 100%.
- It's what they want.
It's what they wanted.
- [Gary] No, I have to go to
LA now for another conference.
- [Driver] Hi.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Driver] We got three?
- [DRock and Jordan] Yeah.
- All right.
(light music)
- Wait a minute, wait a
minute Instagram Stories?
Instagram Stories?
My thoughts are the same as any
time a major platform makes an
update, copies a feature from
somebody else, adjusts to what
somebody else is doing
it's a wait-and-see, right?
I don't actually have many
emotions or thoughts
right off the bat.
I'm more curious of watching
people interact with it
and see what happens.
So it's early,
I think it's important.
I've mentioned my concern about
Instagram's positioning in the
marketplace not too long ago.
I actually think Instagram's
in a weird, vulnerable position.
I don't like they're getting
squeezed right now between
Snapchat and Facebook.
Facebook has its generation and
Snapchat's eating up just too
much of what Instagram had.
Unexpected but exciting.
I think it's a
smart fast follow.
We'll see if it clicks.
I think a lot of times
features are big plays.
I think when Instagram did video
because Vine was out there it in
essence really was a big deal.
This I'm not so sure.
Snapchat's a much bigger player
than Vine was at that point.
We'll see.
Let me just meet
this guy real quick.
Give me one sec.
Skee, my man.
- G. I heard you guys
knew one another.
- This is been like
two years in the making.
- What's up, big time?
- What's up, big man?
Please come. It's gonna
be the best talk here.
I'm dropping the best talk.
- [Skee] What time you?
- [Gary] 2:30.
I'll see you then.
Thank you, man.
- [Man 4] You've done
some incredible things.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- [Man 4] And you
stay very humble
which I think is so critical.
- [Gary] I think so too, man.
I appreciate that and
it's funny when on stage
my ego goes but in real life,
you know it's funny, on camera,
on stage my ego goes
but in this my humility goes.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- [Gary] You know?
- [Man 4] That's the
most important thing.
- I think so.
Who the fuck am I?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- I've know I done well.
There's many other
people that have done well.
The other thing is
I genuinely like people.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Which--
- [Man 4] Is a massive value.
- Yeah, to cut the real
chase that's the saving grace.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- I genuinely like these people.
Thanks for the invite, man.
I just got in this morning.
- Sorry, I actually didn't
even check your Snap afterwards.
- Dude, congrats, congrats,
congrats that's fucking insane.
I can't believe you, you guys
gave me a little preview but it
was only two, dude, wow.
Hello gang.
Is that the Xand-man?
Hi Mooshie.
Hi dwah-dwah.
(blows kisses)
I love you Mooshie brains.
I love you.
(blows kisses)
Bye Mommy.
Love you, Mommy.
So here's my new feature
for Instagram Stories.
I'm going to give you guys
screen savers once a day.
My new screensaver is up next.
Now, let's keep using the
functionality of this amazing
thing, DRock. Anyway message me
right now if you're using
this screensaver. Now.
What up Snapchat?
Would love for you to go check
out my Instagram Story and
I'd love to get your
two cents on it.
Instagram Stories suck.
The same fuckers that loved
Instagram 11 months ago and were
like Snapchat is bullshit are
literally going to say
Instagram Stories are bullshit.
Snapchat's the best.
Same characters.
They hate that change,
DRock, they hate that change.
I love that change.
Because it's inevitable.
You know, I'm playing with it.
I'm making my
first story right now.
First of all, I think it's
a very well-made product.
It's very intuitive even
the first or two go arounds.
I think that's always important
having intuitive
products matters.
I think the UI and the
UX of where they put the
stories is huge.
They're just unmissable.
It's super intuitive, it's a
very well-made product,
that's important.
That's number one, next, it
just comes natural and I usually
things don't naturally come to
me usually so that
was actually a good thing.
Two, I'm fascinated by the UI
and UX of the product where the
most recent five or six are
the ones that show up before you
start sliding which I think is
going to induce a lot of people
to create often to game-ify it
to be one of those things that
is always there when
people open up their Instagram.
So, I think that has the
potential to create a lot of
activity early on which is
probably going to be important
and three, I would say that
anybody that thinks this is
going to kill Snapchat is
completely out of their mind.
That's an incredibly no chance
statement and I would also say
that let's not forget that
Instagram's already had success
I think I said this in the
video with fast following.
Vine and doing video and
that pretty much killed Vine.
There's no shot of killing
Snapchat but I do think there's
a shot for people that have been
able to build big audiences on
Instagram and have not yet built
big audiences on Snapchat
this may create a scenario where
they won't try to create big
audiences on Snapchat and that
alone is a win for Instagram.
Yeah.
It won't kill Snapchat
'cause Snapchat's too big.
That's all.
It's just too big.
Too many people have
too many audiences,
there's too many
people that use it.
Plus, there's a lot of people
that won't give Instagram a shot
here because I think of the
copycat play and out of the
emotion they'll be
like, "Oh, screw that."
I mean what this is gonna
do, what Snapchat taught us is
there's a place for content
that is not that serious.
I think Instagram became a
museum and Snapchat became your
conversations and I think that
what this is gonna do for a lot
of Instagram celebrities, content
producers, media companies,
brands is allow them to produce
a lot more content for Snapchat.
There's a lot of people on
Snapchat that are way too fancy
and only only post one or
two things and they have to be
perfect, this is going to give
them that ability to not be as
perfect which will
make them create more.
All these things start off as
something it could have any
niche that the next big social
network's going to start off
with some niche, some feature,
build critical mass and then
just become a content platform
with every option of every way
to do it. Got it?
It's one of the reasons I'm
surprised that Snapchat has not
started doing live yet.
I just think it's inevitable.
Eventually snackable content,
everygreen content and
live content will be the cost of
entry to be a modern day massive
social network. Boom.
Let's call it "My two cents on
Instagram Stories and
its impact on business."
I think Instagram got too fancy,
like you can only
post once a day.
- It's not authentic anymore.
- Yeah.
It's authentic but it's the
authentic version of your most
prized content of the day.
Good to see you again, brother.
There you go.
- [Man 5] How are you?
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Man 6] Hey.
- [Gary] How are you, man?
Hey Laura.
- Hey, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
'Sup man?
- Ankarino Lara
founder of ThisMoment.
- Very nice man, real pleasure.
I could never stand by
the door to say no people.
I'd be like just sit
on the fuckin' floor.
DRock, you should go outside
and get all the
disappointed patrons.
Thanks for coming.
- [Man 7] Thanks having me.
- 90 minute this is
going to be fucking awesome.
I'm super pumped.
And the thing that I really
try to think about was okay, if
we're gonna have such a distinct,
different group people coming
from music and art and
entrepreneurship, marketing what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna talk
about some theme that I think
really bring the most value
across the board and then
I want to open it up.
95% of this room should be
giving a presentation as well so
the one thing I decided to
talk about was attention.
I think what I've done really
well for the last 20 years of my
life is reverse
engineer attention.
Usually buy it at underpriced,
(crashing sound)
(laughter and chatter)
attention. Attention.
That was set up you all looked.
You all looked.
Do you know how hard it is
to like riff for 90 minutes?
And the thing is, as you know,
I think what's interesting about
how I do it I think this is me
actually am asking more of you a
question, I feel like
I constantly have a library of
three hours worth
of content and--
- [DRock] You're able to rotate?
- and there's always
a mix of it, right?
- [DRock] I think the most
important part is
that you size the room.
You make me feel like
it's for everybody.
- Yeah.
- [DRock] For him, for her.
- Yeah, I think
I'm good at that.
I know that 95 to 98% of you
when you hear the term social
media think of it as something
in the appendix, an afterthought
and more importantly probably
for 80 to 90% of you
something that has zero
impact on your money.
The way I look at all these
platforms very simply is as
gateway drugs to
interpersonal relationships.
(light music)